at CES it's no surprise to find the
latest coolest gadgets things like
tablet PCs ereader zor networked home
appliances but we're pretty sure we've
found the coolest gadget that will drive
your cat's absolutely insane it's called
the Spiro and it works because as a
3-axis accelerometer inside of it pretty
much the same one that you would find
inside of your iPhone or Wii Remote and
it works basically by putting it down on
the ground and use your iOS device or
Android device to remotely navigate it
through pretty much anything a series of
cones you can do it up a ramp and the
developers in Spiro have also included
both created an SDK which will allow you
to create your own apps to pretty much
make the Sphero do whatever you want
there's also included some games with it
golfing game a driving game and in
February they'll be releasing a Simon
like game volva colors as well as a
space fighter game called you guessed it
space fighter now the Sphero is
available at go sparrow calm and it
retails for 129 dollars but remember to
drive your cats absolutely insane it's
worth every penny
you